For experts and emotion interview.
We have the honor speaking with Dr. Joseph Campos from the University of
California Berkeley on emotion development.
Uh,
Doctor Cambos received his phd from Cornell University and completed post
doctoral training and psychophysiology at the Albert Einstein College of
medicine.
His first faculty position was at the University of Denver in infant
psychophysiology and he's currently a professor of psychology at UC Berkeley.
Dr. Campos was one of the founders of the experimental study of human infants in
the late 1960s and his work with babies led to three major areas of original
contribution.
First was the finding that motoric developments such as crawling,
proceed and recently have been shown to cause major changes and emotion
perception,
spatial cognition,
and even language.
Second,
his,
his other contribution came in the field which we now call social referencing,
which is the baby search for and use of emotional information from significant
others to help regulate their behavior.
And his third major contribution has come from what he has called the
functionalists theory of emotions,
which stresses the Equa Fonality and echo potentiality of emotional responses in
the interest of problem solving.
Dr. Campos has edited the volume on emotion and early development and the
handbook of child psychology and was a coauthor of one of the first textbooks in
infant development in 1982 his crew has been marked by awards for distinguished
teaching and was,
he was the president of the International Society for infant studies and the co
founder and first president of the international society for research on
emotions.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Dr. Joseph Campos.
So welcome Joe.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Well,
to see it again June,
that's been I think 10 years in Secretary Smet.
You so maybe not that long,
but uh,
it's good to see you are,
well,
it's good to see you too.
And yes,
it has been about that long,
I would say perhaps even more than 10 years.
So it's exciting feel to have this opportunity to talk with you as one of the
people.
Um,
for a lot of people,
me included.
Um,
that got me excited about emotion in the first place.
Well,
I'm glad they did that.
You asked about why I got into emotion.
Yeah.
What first got you interested in studying emotion?
Well,
that's kind of like asking me,
um,
uh,
what got me interested in breathing.
Uh,
it,
uh,
to me it,
it was just a fundamental,
I found it always interesting to see how people reacted emotionally,
you know,
whether it was my parents or siblings or whether it was my friends,
uh,
are going to a baseball game or a football game.
Emotion who seemed to be everywhere.
And,
um,
if there's one thing that's been constant in my,
my career has been at the interest in the study of emotion and,
um,
uh,
it began with studying at the time when behaviorism rules,
and believe it or not,
my master's thesis was called Masochism and modern goats,
which indicated my interest even with animals.
Because when you condition,
in this case,
it was a goal or set of goats to,
uh,
expect the ucs have a shock.
Uh,
so you'd have a c,
a s a condition stimulus that came on the tone or a buzzer and then a few
seconds later it shock.
The animals seem to be more upset during the time between the condition
stimulus.
In the unconditioned stimulus then when he or she got the shock.
So I decided,
well,
maybe they will bring the shotgun earlier and shock themselves and here's what
they do.
They,
they brought onto the shock earlier.
And so that's why I call it masochism and modern goats.
So subsequently I lost my interest in goat cuisine,
you know,
at the time of the graduate student.
So you ate your subjects.
Uh,
so,
uh,
then I moved down to,
college students and that was an awful lot of fun.
A sledding psychophysiology psychophysiological responses are just wonderful in
terms of being sensitive and keeping you disciplined.
You can be sloppy with psychophysiological indices.
And every time I turned the page and the study of emotion,
I got more and more interested.
So it's a right on the metal.
It's one of those questions that you can't answer directly because as I said,
it's kind of like,
well,
why are you interested in breathing?
Um,
it's just second nature.
And so you're right,
I mean,
emotions are such an integral part of what make us human and just sort of what,
you know,
govern every single part of our life in many ways.
Um,
and so I think your,
your answer makes a lot of sense for many of us out there in terms of what first
got us captured by emotion.
It's,
it's part of our life.
I'm just like breathing.
Um,
what I'd like to ask you a bit now is about your work on emotion,
you know,
this central part of our life.
Um,
and I wanted to start by asking you a bit about some of your work that you're
widely known for.
So this influential work on the visual cliff,
you know,
that demonstrated the power of emotional communication between a young infant
and their caregiver through social referencing.
So I wonder if you could tell us a bit more about this,
um,
for those who may not know about this,
you know,
really powerful phenomena of emotional communication early on in life.
Well,
when I got into the field of emotion and psychology,
the first part of it,
and just making sure that emotions were studied.
Because when I came into the field,
the emotions were anathema.
There were no textbooks on emotion.
They were no entries on emotion in any handbook.
Uh,
there were no chapters on emotion in any handbook.
So,
uh,
the first thing I wanted to do is this goodie emotion per se.
And it turns out that most od behavioral sciences study emotions and emotional
expressions is an outward sign of an internal state.
For example,
the first day in my email today was,
uh,
a call for papers or journal,
the face in the brain.
And that indicates the typical approach,
which is to study how,
uh,
an outward sign of emotion reflects something internal.
But I thought that that was only half the story and you had to turn the coin
over.
And the OBC verse,
emotions are transmitted.
That broadcasts.
They're not just the outward sign of an internal state.
They're not just expressions.
And when I had children,
my wife and I had children,
uh,
I observed is that they kept looking to us,
in certain times in certain contexts.
And um,
that that made to determine methods by which you could study the effects of
emotions,
emotional expressions,
for example,
not as outward signs of an internal state,
but as regulators that the behavior of the other,
I frankly think that that is the real value of emotion,
uh,
in fact that they are crucial in regulating the behavior of others and others
regulating our behavior.
Um,
either way,
a very good illustration and contemporary,
uh,
psychology is a current interest in self conscious emotions like shame.
It's actually misnamed.
It shouldn't be self conscious,
it should be other conscious.
And the interest in self time just emphasizes is solipsistic phenomenon where
all your interested in is what takes place in the brain and the mind.
And then,
uh,
how it goes out to the edge of the body.
And there it stops.
Not so not so.
Other conscious means that when you're in a state of shame,
you had receiving in reality or through attribution,
the social signals of another person which powerfully affect your behavior.
For example,
the scorn of another person,
the disappointment or disgust of another person and so forth.
Um,
same thing with pride.
Uh,
it is the reaction of the oven that matters.
Not this self idea itself is involved in all aspects of emotion.
Don't get me wrong,
but uh,
it is this emphasis on the other that attracted me and actually,
uh,
the view of emotion that I favor.
And that as you know from the seminar that you participated in here at Berkeley,
it was what Dick Lazarus was a relational view of motion where self and other
self and act together like the North Pole and south pole of the magnet operated
in the regulation of behavior or iron filings,
whatever you want to hold them.
So that is what got me involved in what is called social referencing.
I was like,
that term is actually a very narrow in its um,
true designation has become applied more broadly than it was originally intended
to be.
But I hope that I have captured the sense of the importance of approaching your
emotion from this transmission orientation to compliment the expression
orientation.
Yeah,
I mean this is really helpful and I think it's really important to think of
these sort of,
you know,
other conscious emotions as well.
I wondered if you could just say a tiny bit more about sort of the role in fear,
you know,
as an emotion that is transmitted and picked up by an infant that helps them
regulate their behaviors and learn about the world around them,
through the visual cliff experiment,
for example.
Well,
the visual cliff experiment was very successful,
so were reasons that we still don't fully understand,
but,
uh,
this phenomenon is ubiquitous.
It's ubiquitous.
And,
um,
in 1989 earthquake,
I was sitting,
uh,
in front of the very large window and told him and hall a window that faced the
plaza where people just walk past underweight to their automobiles or to the
subway.
And the earthquake hit at five oh four.
And what did you say?
You did not see people,
everybody who was an earthquake,
but you didn't see people look up above to see if a portion of the roofing I've
told them and haul is going to fall on their heads.
No,
they look at each other.
It's so ubiquitous phenomenon.
If you're in an elevator and the elevator suddenly stops,
you don't look at the uh,
uh,
push button device.
You don't look for the telephone,
you can call for an emergency,
help you look at each other.
And in the case of the,
um,
baby,
well let me just give you an example.
One phenomenon that is very,
very important in development is called stranger distress,
used to be called stranger anxiety.
Well,
uh,
some babies show it very strongly and some babies hardly show it at all.
And one of the things that,
uh,
we've noticed is that the baby essentially using the mother's reaction to the
stranger as a means of determining how to behave towards that stranger.
We did a study with Maria Bowsher,
uh,
in which a stranger entered the room.
Very simple experiment.
And the mother greeted the stranger in the same way,
except in terms of the vocalists envelope by which she greeted the stranger.
She said,
a very cheery,
hello,
how are you?
Or a very stern way,
oh,
oh are you?
And then the stranger kept approaching the baby.
And that very simple vocalization which lasted no more than three to five
seconds at the very beginning of the entry of the experiment,
powerfully affected the eight and a half month old baby's reaction to that
stranger.
And if this happens consistently,
the baby is going to learn,
hey,
mommy doesn't seem to like people who have certain characteristics,
um,
or mommy does,
like people who have certain characteristics.
And in addition to other factors,
of course I would include temperament here.
Uh,
the baby essentially learns to catch the emotion of the other person.
And why should an animal it baby become afraid of,
for example,
cockroaches.
Uh,
our younger daughter is terrified of insects.
She's never been bitten by an insect in any manner.
That's crucial.
Um,
but none of us in our family react very friendly to a cockroach and a or to a
grasshopper and she's picked that up.
Hmm.
So,
um,
the social referencing and as a way of learning vicariously sort of the
experiences picked up from the reactions of other people and it's just very
biologically adaptive.
It can also be very biologically on adaptive if,
uh,
the signal is not veridical or is transmitted an odd fashion.
So it's really interesting when we think about just the transmission of emotions
and how we learn and acquire them.
And you know,
with the example you talk about with the earthquake in [inaudible] 89,
just how this stays with us throughout life.
Um,
you know,
it makes me think about other work you've done where you've really pioneered our
understanding of the development of a wide variety of emotions,
including also anger and happiness.
And I wonder if you could say a bit more about what are these emotions look like
when they first emerge?
You know,
perhaps even early in infancy.
Well.
Um,
let me say something that's pretty shocking to here and that is I don't believe
in Lotions,
quote unquote the merge.
I think they become organized.
So there are aspects of emotion that are evident very early and uh,
your baby's life.
And then other aspects of emotion come online.
And as the baby develops,
more and more aspects come together into that gets stalled in terms of the
baby's reaction that we call emotion.
And depending upon where you cut into this,
uh,
develop ETL process of organization and putting components together,
you can say anger develops at a birth,
anger develops at a,
uh,
one month.
Anger develops at three months and go develops at seven months.
So you have to put the question more specifically.
When does a particular aspect of emotion that you are interested in,
uh,
first become quantifiable?
And the second question you have to ask is when there's the element or the
component that you're interested in become linked to other components.
Example,
anger is not just in the face,
it's shown in the voice and mothers will say,
Oh,
my baby is angry.
But did you look at the facial expression of the baby and you quantify it using
any of a number of facial expression coding systems.
And you don't get the,
uh,
pattern facial expression.
But does that mean it the baby's not showing anger but at the voice?
What about the way the baby tenses up?
That's really interesting.
So I mean,
we're talking about this idea of social referencing.
We're talking about when emotions first become organized and infants.
Um,
and a lot of this work really,
you set the stage for,
you know,
and has guided a lot of the way researchers looking at emotional development,
uh,
you know,
will,
will operationalize and measure these constructs.
And I wonder,
you know,
as you see where the fields come from,
in understanding emotional development,
where do you see the face of the future headed,
moving forward?
Well and,
um,
develop battle,
uh,
work.
Obviously the oceans did,
I happened to mentioned as the other conscious,
oh,
oceans have to be studied.
Uh,
some people say for examples of that shame is a master emotion,
the most significant demotion.
And when does it begin?
Um,
and what are its consequences?
How does it transmit to others?
How does it affect other people and what is it about other people to bring it
about?
And uh,
I'm Tom Sheppard,
sociologists have argued about this shame rage spiral is somebody shames you.
Yeah,
you do is draw from social contact,
but you also have a desire just strike back because you're self self play,
a role in the margin has been wounded.
Um,
that's very,
very important.
And the same thing holds true for the other emotions like jealousy.
Even in the bay area in the last week we have had so many horrible crimes all
linked to the emotion of jealousy.
Now to me,
I think that that is an extremely important area that has been relatively,
I'm just studied.
I mean have you did a histogram,
you would get um,
thousand studies of fear and anger and so forth and you would all lead,
you get a little rebuttal.
It'd be drab of studies on these self conscious emotions.
And most of the studies are not done well.
They're not done using a multiday componential approach.
So it's interesting to think about,
you know,
as manifest,
oh,
sorry.
I was just saying it's interesting to think about,
you know,
the role,
self conscious emotions as really being an important piece of where the field is
going to need to move and understanding emotional development.
Yeah.
Um,
and I think then I want to ask you to,
as we think about where the field moves forward,
you know,
and students,
oh,
sorry,
go ahead.
Okay,
no,
go ahead.
Oh,
oh,
sure.
I'll just start over with that question.
But essentially,
so when we think about where the field of emotions headed,
moving forward,
such a big part of what moves it forward,
what the momentum is,
are the current students we had today or future students maybe pondering or
thinking about embarking in the study of emotion.
And so what sort of advice do you give to students who are thinking about,
you know,
embarking or trying to understand you're trying to become part of this movement
in the field of emotion?
Well,
I would like,
uh,
the next generation and students to,
not be lemmings.
We behavioral scientists and probably biological sciences and physical sciences
as well are lemmings.
We tend to follow the leader and we tend to add incrementally to the knowledge
base as a field,
but it does not add to the understanding phase to the field,
and I'm not going to go into the difference between knowledge and understanding,
but the difference is profound.
But I would like to encourage is for people to try to understand emotion and to
understand that if they want to make a solid contribution.
In my experience it's two factors help make for that advanced.
Number one,
there has to be a an idea that's in the air that's a present.
People recognize it
but they,
oh,
I'll get it a bit importance.
And then number two,
develop a method that allows you to investigate the phenomenon as well as you
can when you had a conjunction of a topic that is deemed to be very important
and a method that helps actualize the advancement of our understanding of that
topic.
That is so beginning to emerge,
to be important.
You've got yourself the makings of a solid contribution to understand.
Thank you so much,
Joe,
for speaking with us today.
It's been just a real pleasure to hear your thoughts and insights on not only
emotional development,
but you know,
the field of emotion as a whole.
Well,
I'm sorry that I'm not,
uh,
closer,
so that we could continue our discussions on these issues because of course,
we've only scratched the surface.
Um,
the field is very exciting and if you take out from journals like emotion and
emotion review,
incremental studies that add to the bulk of the Journal,
um,
it turns out that there's quite a bit of true understanding that remains to be
added.
Hm.
And that's a wonderful place to end to think about all the truth that will be,
you know,
to be discovered,
as the field moves forward.
Right.
It's very important.
Well,
thank you again.
Um,
so this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Dr. Joseph Campos from
the University of California at Berkeley.